täglich werden unmengen an amazon
produkte zurück gesendet weil sie nicht
funktionieren oder nicht gefallen oder
was auch immer wenn die ware dann
beschädigt ist oder sie nicht mehr als
neuwertig verkauft werden kann
landet die oft vor allem in amerika in
so riesigen amazon return lagerhalle in
den usa gibt es unzählige videos in
denen leute palettenweise amazon return
ware bestellen und riesige gewinne
machen leider kann man das nicht direkt
nach deutschland bestellen
der versand wäre auch viel zu teuer ich
habe allerdings für ca 150 euro plus
versand ein kleineres paket von einem
händler aus den usa bestellen können so
leid es mir tut darum geht es ja erst im
nächsten video hätte was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen zu 1 9 mio ja leute
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut ich weiß
wir haben uns jetzt sehr lange nicht
gesehen also das könnte schon so 10 12
tage gewesen sein ich habe eine kleine
pause gemacht im jahr verdienste nicht
so gut und habe ein paar andere sachen
gemacht für die ich mich auch
interessieren habe aber auch neue videos
geplant und mache die halt jetzt obwohl
wir immer noch haben eigentlich lohnt
gar nicht nein das war natürlich nur ein
spaß
ich freue mich dass ich wieder hier
sitzen kann wir haben nämlich echt coole
sachen geklagt und heute starten wir
direkt mal rein mit einer sache ja da
dachte ich eigentlich okay das wirst du
in deutschland niemals machen können
leider aber ich habe jetzt doch so
inzwischen weg gefunden um das mal
auszuprobieren das ist in amerika mega
groß es gibt super viele youtuber die
bestellen dort so amazon returns ganz
wichtig leute amazon returns sind nicht
amazon restposten das sind sachen die
von kunden zurückgeschickt wurden
und dann nicht mehr verkauft werden
können denke ich mal und in amerika
findet man das unter den amazon
warehouse deals ja das gibt es in
deutschland auch aber halt ohne return
boxen also du kannst die einfach in
deutschland nicht bestellen das mega
schade aber ich werde nicht einen mega
geil youtuber wenn ich nicht einen weg
gefunden hätte das doch zu tun leute wir
starten heute nämlich rein hier wir
haben hier oben einmal ein paket aus
deutschland das kommt von einem
zwischenhändler der über amazon return
oder retouren ware verfügt die halt
nicht mehr verkauft werden und die dann
sozusagen weiterverkauft habe ich lange
für gesucht aber ich hab' eingefunden
das hat mich glaube ich 65 euro kostet
wir starten auf jeden fall mit diesem
paket hier rein leute ich muss sagen das
hat mich auch einfach gereizt weil ich
hab so viele videos gesehen
ich habe so viel
videos gesehen von leuten die da
wirklich für 100 euro sind return paket
bestellt habe und da waren so geile
sachen drin natürlich weiß man nie ob
steak isst oder wir hier vielleicht
einfach mal ein paar beispiele
eingeblendet also stammt der eine typ
500 euro bestellt und hatte 24.000 euro
waren komplett krass wahrscheinlich fake
ein plan erstellt sogar eine richtung
bei das kommt aus dortmund gesamtbetrag
73 eur 47 hast du jetzt könnt ihr mich
gar nicht mehr sehen
spielzeug retouren und allgemeine
retouren zehn teile okay jetzt bin ich
mal gespannt
hier haben wir auf jeden fall das erste
paket tolles international
also das ist jetzt wirklich glaube ich
für kinder also also ich kann mich ja
sehr gut an die ganzen restposten pakete
von amazon erinnern und da war wirklich
immer nur die größte scheiße drin
und jetzt haben wir hier schon mal so
eine klimas pistole und handschellen und
ein fernglas also finde ich schon mal
gar nicht so schlecht aber ich denke mal
hier ist jetzt nicht so krass ist drin
hierfür mädchen was ist das denn hier
und das sind glaube ich so nah und ich
echt geil autos jede menge autos huber
racers keine ahnung alter das kenne ich
gar nicht ich glaube aus dem alter bin
ich schon raus es ist jetzt auch so
gemischt denke ich mal für jungs und
mädchen die haben wir so krohn
also ich weiß echt nicht was ich damit
anfangen soll weil ich kenne leider
irgendwie nicht mehr so kinder die so
zehn jahre alt sind dann haben wir hier
noch tattoo stickers und dann noch hier
bleistifte heißt es ist halt alles für
kinder das muss man ganz klar sagen wo
kreide was hat sich auch früher mal da
kannst du damit die straße bemalen und
was haben wir hier noch mal so ein auto
sparen sparen audi ist leider schon
kaputt deswegen wurde die wahrscheinlich
oder kann man dann ist also die hat hier
eine delle
vielleicht wurde sie deswegen
zurückgesteckt und kann nicht gar nicht
einschätzen warum man solche sachen
zurück steht das ist ja auch alles noch
original verpackt weil es hat ja auch
sein können dass damit sonst was
passiert dann haben wir hier noch mehr
kreide und ach nein das war auch mal
dass ich so kam es waren aber ich feiere
falls es das ist was ich denke ja man
das ist dass er das hatte ich früher
immer dümmer verrückt
da kommen auf jeden fall gerade eine
menge erinnerungen haben also das ist
doch echt viel drin dann haben wir noch
mal sowas nochmal bleistifte und ja ich
weiß dass es hier haben wir den
elefanten noch eine spirale und noch
eine schildkröte also für kinder geil
ohne witz leute ich kann euch gern mal
den kontakt in die video beschreibung
packen weil so boxen wenn du sowas
kindern schenkt zum kindergeburtstag die
freuen sich doch ein ast oder es ist zum
großteil alleskönners ware aber ich
hatte mich so darüber gefreut aber wenn
ich mir recht sicher zum glück haben wir
noch ein weiteres paket das ist darin
ich hoffe hier sind jetzt geile sachen
drin weil das ist auf jeden fall das
teure so was wir jetzt noch machen
werden
aber der karton ist gleich hoffe da sind
jetzt keine spielzeuge drückt okay das
sieht auf jeden fall für mich schon
deutlich interessanter aus also diese
ganzen spielzeuge werde ich auf jeden
fall irgendwohin spenden denke ich mal
weil ich kann damit nichts anfangen ok
starten immer hier mit hier haben wir
ein home protect yourself and secure wir
werden natürlich so machen wie immer
ich habe für diese dieses paket glaube
ich 540 euro bezahlt und wir werden dann
mal berechnen was das alles wert ist
wobei das jetzt schon so alt aussieht es
halt auf jeden fall um das haus sicherer
zu machen dann haben wir hier noch nicht
so was habe ich noch nie gesehen 1
anteil der sand timer signalisiert ihnen
die maximale aufenthaltszeit in der
sonne misst schädliche uv strahlen soll
man den mitnehmen oder was konkret
weitergeht dann haben wir das gleiche
nochmal hier haben wir dann slim glas
break alarm das heißt wenn jemand eure
scheibe einwirken geht der haltlos so
ich wusste gar nicht dass es so etwas
gibt also es liegt natürlich nahe hier
mit alter boas ein feuerzeug celtic
tiger knopfbatterien safestick aber
einen premium service täglich
mittlerweile dieses safesticks inso
paketen geben mir so unendlich auf den
sack weil das brauche ich einfach nicht
mehr benutzt holzplastik hier haben wir
ein
auf jeden fall haben wir hier ein usb
adapter mit vier zugängen das geil die
wollen wir hier irgendwie so eine handy
hülle jetzt auch nicht dann schon wieder
so was also man es nervt nicht irgendwie
sind im großen und ganzen immer relativ
ähnliche sachen so was drin vor allem
bei dieser cases hast du eigentlich
überall
oh geil ein action camcorder das finde
ich nicht er ist ja auch bestimmt ein
bisschen was wert action camcorder vier
gigabyte
naja ok ich glaube der ist eigentlich
nicht mehr viel wert weil so wie der
aussieht der stammt aus dem jahr 2014
hier ist jetzt stimmt wieder sowas mit
power bank drin in der glühbirne
dann haben wir hier wahrscheinlich noch
eine glühbirne gut so was kann man immer
mal gebrauchen
also ich will jetzt nicht sagen dass das
paket von grund auf total cup ist es
sind auch brauchbare dinge dabei hier
haben wir dann noch kopfhörer dann haben
wir hab ich gesehen noch andere
kopfhörer war das sind halt wirklich die
sind auch schon relativ alt wie wurden
auch 2014 hergestellt und sind heute
halt einfach nichts mehr wert
das muss man auch ganz klar sagen und
dann haben wir hier noch mehr kopfhörer
immer man sieht auch richtig und an den
verpackungen für das iphone 5 und
hierfür die kamera ja ich weiß auch
nicht dann hier noch einen bäcker und zu
guter letzt dann ist das paket auch leer
haben wir hier ein taschen erlernt man
irgendwo ist es auch klar wenn du dir so
ein händler suchst in deutschland der
sagt er hat amazon return pakete oder
zurück geschickte ware die er nicht mehr
verkauft werden kann und ich zahle ihm
für diese ganzen sachen zum beispiel 45
euro der will ja auch sein geschäft
machen und wenn irgendwas davon wirklich
noch ein wert hätte würde er ist
wahrscheinlich auch selber verkaufen
also das war jetzt im großen und ganzen
nicht so lies es kommen aber wieder
richtig geile videos ich habe super
coole interessante themen und das kommt
jetzt alles wieder online deswegen
abonniert super gerne den kanal würde
ich mich sehr darüber freuen und wir
sehen uns dann hier die nächsten tage
wieder mit einem geilen video
trotzdem danke fürs zuschauen leute haut
rein